This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2005, I took a job at WBEZ in Chicago, and I was so excited to be moving there. I was excited about the job, of course, but I was also very excited about the grid. The streets of Chicago and the address numbering system are beautiful.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2005年，我在芝加哥的WBEZ电台找到了一份工作，当时我非常兴奋能搬到那里。当然，我对这份工作感到兴奋，但我对那里的城市网格系统也感到非常兴奋。芝加哥的街道和地址编号系统非常美妙。
Starting from the 00 access point downtown, the streets conform to a rigid grid pattern where the major streets are exactly one mile apart and have address numbers which are in multiples of 800. You don't really have to be able to picture this, but I know that if you know it, you're nodding your head vigorously, but just know that it's amazing and I was mesmerized by it. So much so that I made flashcards with Chicago Street names on one side, and the corresponding address number on the other so that my wife and I could quiz ourselves on the 2,000-mile road trip from San Francisco to Chicago. Yes, I was always like this.
从市中心的00坐标点开始，街道遵循着严格的网格模式，主要街道之间正好相隔一英里，地址编号以800为倍数。你其实不需要在脑海中想象这个画面，但我知道如果你了解它，你现在一定在用力点头。只需知道它非常神奇，我当时完全被它迷住了。以至于我制作了抽认卡，一面写着芝加哥的街道名称，另一面写着相应的地址编号，这样我和我妻子在从旧金山到芝加哥的2000英里公路旅行中就可以互相测试。是的，我一直都是这样的人。
Division is 1200 North. Armourtage is 2000 North, and therefore one mile north of division. After living in the jungle of San Francisco streets for years, the thought of moving to a place where people plan the city to help people know where they were and where they were going sooth my lizard brain and gave me peace. and gave me peace. As humans have developed cities and built environments, we have also needed to develop ways to find our way through them. Signage goes back at least as far as the Roman Empire.
Division街是北纬1200号。Armitage街是北纬2000号，因此它在Division街以北一英里处。在旧金山那如同丛林般的街道上生活了多年后，想到要搬到一个人们为了帮助大家辨别方向而规划城市的地方，这安抚了我原始的大脑，让我感到平静。随着人类开发城市和建造环境，我们也需要开发出在其中找到方向的方法。标识系统的历史至少可以追溯到罗马帝国时期。
They constructed milestones along their roadways. Which is to say, if you're relying on anything besides natural features to help you find your way around, you are relying on things made by people whose job it is, is to help us figure out how to get from all of our respective point A's to our point B's. Our producer Sam Greenspan would like me to tell you that he has a fantastic sense of direction. I really do. I get lost some times all of a minute.
他们在道路沿线建造了里程碑。也就是说，如果你除了自然特征之外还要依靠其他东西来帮你辨别方向，那么你就是在依靠那些以帮助我们从各自的A点到达B点为职业的人所创造的东西。我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘想让我告诉你，他的方向感极好。我确实很好。我有时会迷路，哪怕只有一分钟。
It's the worst. I get lost some times, I'll admit it. It's the worst. I get so mad at myself when it happens. But now, my life is completely different ever since I started thinking about what it means that wayfinding is a thing. Wayfinding, in this sense, is a branch of environmental graphic design, concerned with helping people find their way. I love knowing this, because now, when I get lost in a hospital or in a complicated freeway
那是最糟糕的。我有时会迷路，我承认。那是最糟糕的。发生这种情况时，我对自己非常生气。但现在，自从我开始思考“寻路”这一概念的意义后，我的生活完全不同了。从这个意义上说，寻路是环境图形设计的一个分支，旨在帮助人们找到方向。我很高兴知道这一点，因为现在，当我在医院或复杂的立交桥
interchange or at an airport, I have someone to blame. Yeah, that's one way to look at it, but a lot of times it has nothing to do with the signage. You can use an error or does a plot sometimes. Fair enough, let me introduce you to Jim Harding. My name is Jim Harding. I'm an environmental graphic designer. Basically, I tell people where to go.
或机场迷路时，我有人可以责怪了。是的，这是一种看待问题的方式，但很多时候这与标识无关。有时确实是用户错误。说得有道理，让我为你介绍一下吉姆·哈丁。我叫吉姆·哈丁。我是一名环境图形设计师。基本上，我负责告诉人们该往哪里走。
There's an environmental graphic designer or wayfinder, or maybe just a kid with a magic marker, behind every sign. Turn here to merge onto the 101. Concoursey is this way. Bathrooms straight ahead. But there is a lot, lot more to way finding than just signage. Signage is probably the least effective tool of wayfinding. Good architecture is one of the best. It's not that Jim hates signs. Rather the best forms of
在每个标志背后，都有一位环境图形设计师、寻路专家，或者可能只是一个拿着记号笔的孩子。在此转弯以汇入101号公路。大厅往这边走。洗手间就在前面。但寻路不仅仅是标识。标识可能是寻路中最不有效的工具。优秀的建筑设计才是最好的工具之一。并不是吉姆讨厌标志。相反，最好的寻路形式
wayfinding are, shall we say, invisible. They're baked into the built environment. I first heard about Jim Harding through a writer named David Zweig. I'm David Zweig, I'm a writer. My book is called Invisible, the power of anonymous work in an age of relentless self-promotion. David's Wig's book is a series of portraits of people whom he refers to as Invisible. Invisible are people who are highly skilled professionals, people who are really important to whatever enterprise or endeavor that they're a part of, that their work really has a big effect on the overall outcome, but yet who are largely unknown, never thought of by the public or the end user. Jim Harding, director of Environmental Graphics for Aggression Smith and Partners, is one
可以说是隐形的。它们融入了建筑环境之中。我第一次听说吉姆·哈丁是通过一位名叫大卫·茨威格的作家。我是大卫·茨威格，我是一名作家。我的书叫《隐形：在无休止的自我推销时代匿名工作的力量》。大卫·茨威格的书是一系列人物肖像，他称这些人为“隐形人”。隐形人是那些技术精湛的专业人士，他们对所参与的任何企业或事业都至关重要，他们的工作对最终结果有很大影响，但他们却鲜为人知，从未被公众或最终用户想到。吉姆·哈丁，Aggression Smith and Partners的环境图形总监，就是其中
such invisible. Jim Harding is one of the best in the business. Jim worked on the new international terminal at Hartfield Jackson International Airport in Atlanta, Georgia, the world's busiest. 100 million passengers move through it every year, all of them needing to know where to go. Scylons are so important, because if you can see your destination, you don't have to rely on signs. I met Jim at the Atlanta Airport, and he walked me through some of the cutting edge wayfinding techniques that he employed at the new international terminal.
一位隐形人。吉姆·哈丁是业内最优秀的人之一。吉姆参与了佐治亚州亚特兰大哈茨菲尔德-杰克逊国际机场新国际航站楼的设计，这是世界上最繁忙的机场。每年有1亿名乘客通过这里，他们都需要知道该往哪里走。标识非常重要，因为如果你能看到目的地，就不必依赖标志。我在亚特兰大机场见到了吉姆，他带我了解了他在新国际航站楼采用的一些尖端寻路技术。
Like right when you walk in from curbside, the physical space tells you everything you need to know about how to move through it, without even realizing it. Let's start with the first thing you want when you enter the airport, the ticket counter. You're not lined up on a 90 degree access, they're angled, okay? A lot of times the ticket counter just meets you head on when you walk in and then you're left to wonder Okay, I go left or right, where's the sign for my gate? But these angled ticket counters subtly push you in the right direction. The angle Steers you down and around the ticket counter and heading toward the security checkpoint. As the counter is pushing you
就像你从路边走进来时，物理空间会让你在不知不觉中了解如何穿过它。让我们从你进入机场时最先需要的东西开始：值机柜台。你不是排在90度的轴线上，它们是倾斜的，对吧？很多时候，当你走进来时，值机柜台直接迎面而来，然后你就会纳闷：我该往左还是往右？我的登机口标志在哪里？但这些倾斜的值机柜台会微妙地引导你走向正确的方向。这个角度引导你沿着值机柜台绕过去，前往安检处。当柜台推动你时，
You're also getting pulled by this giant three-story glass window that looks out onto the tarmac. You see planes, you see the apron, the jet way where the planes are parking, and so intuitively you're drawn to your planks. That's what you want to go. You want to get on that plane, right? And there are less obvious cues too, like the tile pattern in the floor. Absolutely. When you see the grid, instead of being on a 90 degree axis, it's on a 45. And these tiles going off at a 45 degree angle, they just beckon you to follow them. And so if you do that, you inevitably head toward security. But there's even more going on in the floor than that. And here's where this gets a little
你也会被这扇巨大的三层楼高的玻璃窗所吸引，它可以看到停机坪。你看到飞机，看到停机坪，看到飞机停靠的廊桥，所以你直觉地被吸引到你的飞机那里。那是你想去的地方，你想登上那架飞机，对吧？还有一些不那么明显的线索，比如地板上的瓷砖图案。绝对是这样。当你看到网格时，它不是在90度轴线上，而是在45度角上。这些以45度角延伸的瓷砖，它们在召唤你跟随它们。所以如果你这样做，你不可避免地会走向安检。但地板上发生的事情远不止于此。这就是变得有点
bananas. You turn around and look back here, Sam. You see where the black starts at the door from the curb side. There's another set of tiles inside the dominant grid pattern that I didn't even notice at first. It starts black and then it's joined by a set of yellow goldish tiles that kind of cleaves out this corridor of negative space, which cuts straight through the hall going directly to security.
疯狂的地方。你转过身看看这里，萨姆。你看到黑色从路边入口处开始的地方了吗？在主导网格图案中还有另一组瓷砖，我起初甚至没有注意到。它从黑色开始，然后加入了一组黄色的金色瓷砖，它在某种程度上开辟了一条负空间的走廊，直接穿过大厅通往安检处。
I've already had my ticket, I'm not checking any bags. I don't need to check in on it in the counter. I just follow the yellow brick road, so to speak. I follow the yellow brick road. It's amazing. That's exactly what it is, the yellow brick road. That's exactly what this is. The little white bowl.
我已经拿到了票，不需要托运任何行李。我不需要在柜台办理登机手续。我只是沿着“黄砖路”走，可以这么说。我沿着黄砖路走。太神奇了。这正是它所代表的，黄砖路。这正是它的样子。那个小白碗。
Yeah. It's clicking on, yeah. It's pretty cool. And all of this Jim says is 100% intentional. Absolutely. Our interior designers went through a number of flooring, patterned design schemes until we arrived at this one. On the other side of security, we enter what Jim Harding calls the transition hall. Here's where a traveler has some decisions to make, whether it's to find to get here or whether
是的。它正在起作用，是的。这很酷。吉姆说，所有这些都是100%刻意设计的。绝对是。我们的室内设计师在确定这个方案之前，研究了许多地板图案设计方案。在安检的另一侧，我们进入了吉姆·哈丁所说的过渡大厅。在这里，旅客需要做出一些决定，无论是找到登机口，还是
to get to another concourse, you take a subway called the plane train for that, or whether to head to baggage claim. This is the part where passengers are going to be asking themselves. Where am I? Where am I going? How do I know the best way to get there? Jim says that in these places, where there are decisions to be made, this is where way finding is needed the most. You have the visual way finding which is the signage.
前往另一个大厅，你需要乘坐名为“飞机列车”的地铁，或者前往行李提取处。这是乘客会问自己的地方：我在哪里？我要去哪里？我怎么知道到达那里的最佳路线？吉姆说，在这些需要做出决定的地方，正是最需要寻路系统的地方。你有视觉寻路，也就是标识。
You know, you can see it, you can read it, you can interpret it, find your way around. There's also an information desk and a newfangled interactive display. I walk with Jim towards the gates. Here's F7, F9, so it looks like the odds are on the left. All right, you're into the wayfinding the scene there. This concourse is pretty streamlined, elegant even, but at older, less well-designed concourses, which are definitely present at some other parts of the ATL Airport, this is where you'd find yourself in a visual morass.
你知道，你可以看到它，阅读它，解读它，找到你的方向。还有一个问讯处和一个新颖的交互式显示屏。我和吉姆一起走向登机口。这是F7，F9，看起来单数在左边。好的，你已经进入了那里的寻路场景。这个大厅相当精简，甚至很优雅，但在一些较旧、设计不太好的大厅里，这些大厅在亚特兰大机场的其他部分确实存在，这就是你会发现自己陷入视觉混乱的地方。
You've seen this before, neon signs and brightly colored displays, all trying to get you to buy magazines or neck pillows or hot dogs. You have advertising, you have concessions, marketing, all those visual elements compete with the primary message of just how to navigate the airport. And so the key here is to make the signage stand out by being dull and drab and plain. Yeah, it's very neutral. It's a neutral palette gray and white basically. So you can spot the signs just by tuning out all the glitz.
你以前见过这种情况，霓虹灯标志和色彩鲜艳的显示屏，都试图让你购买杂志、颈枕或热狗。你有广告、特许经营、营销，所有这些视觉元素都与如何导航机场的主要信息竞争。所以这里的关键是通过让标识变得沉闷、单调和朴素来使其脱颖而出。是的，它非常中性。基本上是一个中性的灰色和白色调色板。所以你可以通过屏蔽掉所有的浮华来发现标志。
Now even though this new international terminal is fairly minimal, there are still people trying to sell you stuff. Just beyond the transition hall towards the gates, there's this two level commerce area. There's shopping at ground level and then up and escalator are some food options. And of course it's all angled perfectly so you have a direct line of sight into all the shops as you're walking by. Is that an intentional design to have the shopping down below in the food up above? Yes.
现在，尽管这个新的国际航站楼相当简约，但仍然有人试图向你推销东西。在过渡大厅之外通往登机口的路上，有一个两层的商业区。底层有商店，自动扶梯上去后有一些餐饮选择。当然，这一切都经过了完美的角度设计，这样当你走过时，你可以直接看到所有的商店。将购物区设在下方，餐饮区设在上方，这是刻意的设计吗？是的。
Why is that? Well, more curb appeal for your retail tenants. If they're hungry, they're going to go find the food wherever it is, right? Well, here's the airport. It's a struggle to generate revenue. Really? Yeah. And so anything they can do to help increase non-aeronautical revenue, things that are not generated by a plane or an airline, so improving their concessions and retail, you know, they get a percentage of all those sales. And
为什么会这样？嗯，为了给你的零售租户带来更多的路边吸引力。如果他们饿了，他们会去寻找食物，无论它在哪里，对吧？嗯，这就是机场。增加收入是一场斗争。真的吗？是的。所以他们能做的任何事情来帮助增加非航空收入，即不是由飞机或航空公司产生的收入，比如改善他们的特许经营和零售，你知道，他们会从所有这些销售额中获得百分比。而且
that's when I realize why there are people like Jim Harding who are paid to do this work. It's not just that airports want us to have a pleasant experience, it's because there's money on the table. Think about it. Say you're trying to make a connecting flight, you don't have a lot of time, you don't only know where you're going. I'm stressed, and I don't think I'm going to catch my flight. Am I going to take time to open my wallet?
那时我意识到为什么会有像吉姆·哈丁这样的人被雇佣来做这项工作。不仅仅是因为机场希望我们有愉快的体验，还因为有钱可赚。想一想。假设你正在赶转机航班，你没有太多时间，你不仅不知道你要去哪里。我很紧张，我不认为我能赶上我的航班。我会花时间打开钱包吗？
Heck no. But if I'm cool, calm, collected, if I'm my gait, I know where I'm going, I'm more likely to stop and buy whatever. So that's where Wayfinding has a real financial impact to an airport's bottom line. And so it turns out Wayfinding isn't just about helping you figure out how to get where you want to go. It's about steering the masses anywhere that companies hiring the wayfinders want the masses to be steered.
当然不会。但如果我很冷静、沉着、镇定，如果我知道我要去哪里，我就更有可能停下来买任何东西。这就是寻路对机场底线产生真正财务影响的地方。所以事实证明，寻路不仅仅是关于帮助你弄清楚如何到达你想去的地方。它是关于将大众引导到雇佣寻路专家的公司希望大众被引导去的任何地方。
And what's more, if your consumer choices aren't going to make money for the powers that be inside of a closed system like an airport, don't plan on them making it easy for you. David's Wig, the writer who introduced me to Jim Harding, he noticed this kind of thing too. Their job isn't always about creating the best system for us, the traveler, sometimes it's who's paying their bills. When I flew to Florida with my family,
更重要的是，如果你的消费选择不能为机场这种封闭系统内的当权者赚钱，就别指望他们会让你轻松。大卫·茨威格，那位把我介绍给吉姆·哈丁的作家，他也注意到了这一点。他们的工作并不总是关于为我们这些旅客创造最好的系统，有时取决于谁在付钱。当我带着家人飞往佛罗里达时，
we flew into Fort Lauderdale, and we foolishly chose an off-site car rental company. Oh, rookies. Yeah, big mistake. We thought like, oh off-site, it's like you take a shuttle bus, you're there in two minutes. Well, what happened is, when you arrive there, there's huge signs for Hertz and Avis and all the companies who are there. If you're trying to find the off-site car rental companies, good luck.
我们飞往劳德代尔堡，我们愚蠢地选择了一家场外租车公司。哦，菜鸟。是的，大错特错。我们想，哦，场外，就像你坐穿梭巴士，两分钟就到了。好吧，发生的事情是，当你到达那里时，有赫兹和安飞士以及所有在那里的公司的巨大标志。如果你试图找到场外租车公司，祝你好运。
And then if you try doing that with two little kids in tow, woof. David mentioned this to Jim Harding. They said, Jim, this seems like a wayfinding failure. And he said, well, the airport is far more interested in helping out the people who are paying them, who have on-site facilities. They have no incentive to have you leave the airport
然后如果你带着两个小孩尝试这样做，哎呀。大卫向吉姆·哈丁提到了这一点。他们说，吉姆，这看起来像是一个寻路失败。他说，嗯，机场对帮助那些付钱给他们、拥有场内设施的人更感兴趣。他们没有动力让你离开机场
to go to someone else. They generate no revenue. Yeah, so there's almost like second-class citizen. Yeah. That's not to say though that there's necessarily a dichotomy between capitalism and good user experience. Why do we do what we do for living as way funders? And I think it is, you know, in our own little way
去寻找别人。他们产生不了收入。是的，所以几乎就像二等公民。是的。不过，这并不是说资本主义和良好的用户体验之间必然存在二分法。我们作为寻路专家为什么以此为生？我认为，这是以我们自己的小方式
to improve overall quality of life, that customer experience, passenger experience. And so you work on a project like the International Terminal here in Atlanta, you work on it for years. And after all that time, it's built. And you get to walk through it, and you see it like we are today. You see people using the space, understanding the space. They aren't stressed or freaking out about missing a flight.
来提高整体生活质量，那种客户体验，乘客体验。所以你参与像亚特兰大国际航站楼这样的项目，你为此工作了多年。经过所有这些时间，它建成了。你有机会走过它，就像我们今天这样。你看到人们在使用这个空间，理解这个空间。他们没有因为错过航班而感到紧张或抓狂。
And it's like, okay, wow, you know, it all works. We did a good job and you just come away with a nice sense of satisfaction. Welcome aboard the plane train. Please hold on, this train is departing. In theory, wavefinding should work whether you're literate in it or not. But learning to see the subtle wavefinding cues in the boat landscape can help you understand how you make your decisions. Or it can make you question if you're the one even making your own decisions at all.
就像是，好的，哇，你知道，一切都奏效了。我们做得很好，你只会带着一种很好的满足感离开。欢迎乘坐飞机列车。请抓好扶手，列车即将出发。理论上，无论你是否识字，寻路都应该有效。但学习观察建筑景观中微妙的寻路线索可以帮助你理解你是如何做出决定的。或者它会让你质疑，你是否真的是那个做出自己决定的人。
After I parted ways with Jim Harding, I passed a food court, and I noticed right outside in the floor were these big black curvy tiles, and they actually seemed to be steering people towards the concessions. So you know, next time you find yourself at an airport food court eating a cinnabon that you didn't even want, check out the signage, the shape of the tiling, the height of the ceiling, the quality of the light. It may just be that you have an environmental graphic designer to blame. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know, user error does apply. But you know,, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars.
在我和吉姆·哈丁分道扬镳后，我经过一个美食广场，我注意到地板外面有这些大的黑色弯曲瓷砖，它们似乎确实在引导人们走向特许经营店。所以你知道，下次你在机场美食广场吃着你甚至不想吃的肉桂卷时，看看标识、瓷砖的形状、天花板的高度、光线的质量。可能只是因为你有一个环境图形设计师可以责怪。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，用户错误确实适用。但你知道，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign. Our favorite architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You could only listen to these episodes of 99% of visible MBJS 5. But if you want to be ath-level 99PI Paladin, you should follow us on Twitter. We're at Roman Mars, Sam Lissons, Katie Mingle, and Trouffleman, live show and office hours' announcements
我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，由ArcSign办公室制作。我们最喜欢的建筑公司位于美丽的奥克兰市中心。你只能收听这些《99%隐形》的剧集。但如果你想成为一名99PI圣骑士，你应该在Twitter上关注我们。我们是罗曼·马尔斯、萨姆·利森斯、凯蒂·明格尔和特鲁夫曼，现场演出和办公时间的公告
can be found most reliably on Facebook. We're also all over Tumblr, Instagram, Flickr, SoundCloud, and Spotify too. And you're always welcome at our home on the web at 99PI.org. I'm buying a synopon at the airport that I arrived at. You understand why that's extra disgusting, right? you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以在Facebook上最可靠地找到。我们也活跃在Tumblr、Instagram、Flickr、SoundCloud和Spotify上。我们也随时欢迎你访问我们的网站99PI.org。我在我到达的机场买了一个肉桂卷。你明白为什么这格外令人恶心，对吧？你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。